He was the richest man in America.
The world at his fingertips bans,
yes,
he was a prisoner to his own dark fears.
His achievements were astounding.
He created the fastest plane on the planet,
was the driving force behind the largest aircraft ever built and was a pioneer
in film making,
and yet he is remembered for the eccentricities that drove him from hero to
harness in his heyday.
He was a romantic figure with movie style.
It's blocking to be seen on his own,
and yet he spent the last 26 years of his life as a recluse,
obsessed with cleanliness and controlling every aspect of his environment.
Even as he sunk deeper and deeper into madness and this biographics episode,
we entered these strange worlds of the original eccentric billionaire Howard
Hughes.
When it comes to the life of Howard Hughes,
it can be a challenge to separate fact from fiction.
Even the details of his birth were falsified.
Official records give that date as December the 24th,
19,
85 in Houston,
Texas.
The reality is that it had been born two months earlier in the oil town of
humble,
100 miles from Texas,
from there for you as well.
They just built upon each other and he was not one of triplets,
nor was his mother's sisters,
illegitimate son or a substance user baby brought in to replace the one who had
died.
All these fanciful stories were later told by the man himself in order to build
upon the aura that surrounded his name,
you senior known as both a shortened form of his middle name.
Roberts had been a penniless scoundrel bombing his way around Joplin,
Missouri at the turn of the 19th century in 18,
99.
He was running out of the town by the furious father of a girl who he tried to
seduce with no other options that dreamy eyed laracon decided to try his hand at
the oil business,
making his way to Texas,
but just happened to be on hands when he thousand foot spume of black oil itself
from the grounds at spindletop on January the 10th of 19.
Oh one.
He was among the first to grab claims,
buying our plans for a few dollars and Acre and selling it only days later,
hundreds of dollars within a few months,
having amassed a small fortune boom.
Moved to Houston where he found it.
The Texas oil fuel company,
vf four runner to tax code within six months.
He had also married the darkly prettier but seriously hypochondriacal Ilene
Garner,
Eileen.
She was terrified of small animals and had an insect phobio fueled by an
obsession with cleanliness via straights.
Well,
they were defined full expression in her son by the time that Howard junior
known as sunny,
entered the world in 19 Oh,
five.
His father was still chasing oil still.
He was frustrated not so much as finding the oil locations,
but at the inferior quality of the drilling tools that were available.
Finally,
out the exasperations,
he set his sights on designing a better drill bit.
On November the 20th,
1,980 emerged from his study with designs for a bis the contained to 168 cutting
edges.
He had just invented the Hughes tool,
this from which would flow the millions of dollars,
which would both enrich and ultimately destroy his son App by the age of four.
It was obvious that sunny hughes had inherited the partial deafness that run in
the family,
the condition it will become progressively worse over Howard's lifetime.
As a youngster,
he had caused him to become isolated and introspective.
Now that money was no object,
so the eight year olds cues was sent to an exclusive private school.
He didn't make a very good impression though with a head teacher remembering him
as an upper to snobbish and bore who refuse to join in with the other boys
preferring to sit with the girls.
Not surprisingly,
he seemed gains a reputation as a sissy,
but the young Hughes,
he also gained a reputation as a technical whiz kids.
He put together his first wireless radio transmitter when he was only 11 years
old.
A year later,
his picture appeared in the local newspaper,
proudly standing next to the first and motorized bicycle and Houston,
which he had put together from a steam engine and an effort to get his nervous
and timid boy to man up.
Boy decided to pack him off to camp over the day,
which was the boy scouts.
So during the 1916 summer recess suddenly found himself in the middle of the
[inaudible] mountains in Pike County,
Pennsylvania.
He was under the tutelage of a grizzled old timer by the name of General Dan
Beard.
Surprisingly,
the young Hughes he took to the woodsmen life,
lengthy proverbial duck to water.
It was already quite quickly,
learn to whistle effects Indian signs and simulate bird calls.
He seemed to excel under the military discipline of the camp to away from the
over protective of his mother.
It seemed he was able to shake off his feminine nature and show his true colors.
In the fall of 1920,
a 14 year old son,
he went with his father to v Harvard,
Yale and rowing crew races in Connecticut.
He's seen me,
I promise to buy his son.
Whatever he wanted,
if it's favorite,
Harvard won that race,
went Harvard,
smashed Yale.
By 14 seconds.
The boy held out his hand and expectation and asked for $5.
He then pointed to a selling further up the rhythm.
Advertising rides on a flying boat for $5.
Do Senior reluctantly joined his son for the 10 minute flight.
It made the for the sick,
but the sun had just discovered the one true love of his life.
You found the experience of flying both exhilarating and liberating from that
moment on,
he would be asking is most peaceful when he was alone in an airplane flying high
above a wells.
The tea so often tried to escape
by the age of 19.
Both of his parents were dead.
His mother had died suddenly when he was 16 off suffering complications from an
ectopic pregnancy died less than two years later,
have a heart attack leaving Hughes Jr.
The ad of the hughes tool company.
He dropped ouT of college to take control of the company quickly.
discovering that he knew nothing about the oil business.
He seemed hired a self taught accountants buying the name of tHem.
Though a direct to take feed controls at the same time he was legally declared
himself an adult and seized full control of the entire family.
Fortunately,
here's now had the money that he needed to pursue his greatest passions.
Those passions well,
they had nothing to do with oil.
Instead they revolved around building and flying airplanes and also making
movies in hollywood and other of his passions was actually gulf.
Well,
one's a while playing at the beverly hills country club.
He wants.
She's a biplane,
flew overhead and tipped his wing.
Tanner howard was able to track down to fly and offered to pay him the
outrageous sum of $800 per day if he would teach them to find the probably well
the readily agreed in two years later he was was issued his private pilot's
license.
It's like just cHronic shyness.
Howard was fascinated with the glitz and glamor of hollywood in order to break
into the business.
He's signed a talented director,
lewis milestone to a three year contract.
The pairing thing immediately struck gold with their debut picture to arabian
nights claiming and academy award in 1927.
This gave us the confidence to take on his next challenge,
a fusion of his two great loves flying and movies,
failing,
defining the director who shared his passion for the skies.
Howard decided to go to loan writing,
producing and directing the world's first true aviation picture.
It was called hell's angels.
this was going to be his magnum opus,
and he was prepared to pour in as much money,
time and effort as was needed to create this masterpiece.
An athlete who was contracted that was bigger than that of some countries during
aerial filming sequences.
Howard's obsessive compulsion led him to fixate on such things as cloud
formations.
He would scrap a valuable minutes of perfectly good footage forcing his pilots
to reshoot until the clouds would just for ryan
one day cubes in an effort to control every aspect of an aerial shoots.
He went and taught in a small plane,
but no sooner had he centered than the plane went into a tailspin and crashed
into the ground.
Howard's managed to walk away uninjured.
The first of a number of miraculous plane crash escapes start that actually
commented,
that hasn't injured his check writing.
Um,
so how is obsession with perfection that men's,
the shooting schedule for hell's angels got totally out of control.
In the meantime,
the public had become infatuated with the latest hollywood innovation talkies
against everyone's advice.
Here's decided to do rescripts in the movie and reshoot all of the dialogue
scenes.
This time adding sound.
The reshoots proved to be the break of a for reform and pits plan named holly
and compensate.
The leading lady of the movie reads a nissen wiscosh because of the strong
norwegian accent and carpenters stepped into the role,
he was transformed her into jean harlow,
the platinum blonde bombshell.
He became a sensation during the 19 thirties hell's angels.
It was a box office mash,
returning double its production cost.
$4,000,000,
which was an exorbitant announced at that time.
Unfortunately for us,
three movies,
flops followed.
They've managed to cash in on the public's obsession with al capone by producing
the movie scarface.
We've actually got a biographics video on him as well.
You can find it in a link in the description below.
All right,
so here's,
where's one of these guys?
He always wanted to push the boundaries and films this movie with all of the
violence and all of the absurdities that you'd imagined would be associated with
al capone.
Not surprisingly,
the sensors knocks it back,
the moms in major edits to the movie,
and so that surprise hughes sued them and won.
The theme would be released just as as it intended for.
This is the story of scarface.
Tony,
come on.
His lust for power.
Fancy women.
No work too hard.
I just finish up tonight,
so after the release of scarface,
hughes decided to step back from hollywood's too indulgent is other great
passion and that of course was flying
in 1934.
He easily won a flying race in miami.
This success fueled his ambitions,
inspiring him to set up the hughes aircraft.
Company emails set helped to design and build for wells false desk racing plane.
The results of all of his efforts was the h one which used to a new world speed
record.
Three hundred 52 miles per hour on august the 18th of 1935 by 1938.
Hughes was intends on achieving another wells fest.
The fastest flight around the welds and the modified lockied 14 and he took to
the skies with a handpicked crew and set off from New York 16 hours and 38
minutes later they landed in paris to moscow and then area three days,
19 hours and 14 minutes after setting out.
They were back in New York.
He was hailed as a conquering hero in for three days the pink for these shiny
adventurer in dod,
ticker tape parades and receptions in New York,
chicago,
Washington,
and houston.
In 1940,
he was moved into commercial aviation blind grabbing a controlling share of
trans world airlines or two,
a short time later,
the us government cooling.
They wanted hughes aircraft do supply plain bod salt,
hillary shells and cannon barrels to help support the war effort in europe.
Ten years later with America well anD truly immersed in the conflicts.
Hughes was contracted to design,
build a massive flying boats in order to overcome the german u boat menace that
was causing serious problems for us transport vessels.
So while doing the testing and design for these projects,
hughes was involved in his fourth plane crash.
He was testing a sikorsky as 43 amphibian aircraft on the lake mead,
Nevada.
The plane went down into the frigid waters and it actually killed a ca inspector
and an engineer who will also on board the vessel hughes.
He wants again,
managed to walk away or that you did receive a large gash to the top.
it was around this time that hughes began to exhibit patterns of behavior that
seems odd to you only look,
it's compulsive handwashing to avoid germs,
checking and rechecking his work and always thinking cemetery,
constantly trying to make things perfect.
All classic signs of ocd.
We're seeing symptoms of a deteriorating mind.
This was hardly a good time for whispers of insanity with his business empire,
rapidly expanding it as business contracts imposing wheezy demands.
Hughes was facing stresses and pressures from all directions to huge contracts
for the xf.
Eleven reconnaissance,
blaine and the h k one spruce goose were both over budget and they were overdue.
Most of the deletes that would do to hughes hughes's incessant tinkering and his
insistence on being the test pilot for both planes and well.
There was this insistence which brought about his closest color,
yet on july the seventh,
19,
46 years,
took the xf 11 for its first ever test flights over the los angeles basin.
Now for the first 45 minutes,
this plane functioned perfectly.
Then suddenly a propeller malfunction caused the plane to plummet to the ground,
desperately wrestling with the controls hughes hope to land on a fairway at the
los angeles country club in stats,
the plunge through the roof of a nearby house.
this it was one crash that hughes he wasn't able to walk away from.
It was extracted from the record as it went up in flames and rushed to the
hospital
after ripping the corner from two homes in beverly hills,
California.
The plane finally plunged into this house.
The force of the impact virtually wrecked the building and caused the plane to
catch fire.
He suffered severe head trauma and ben's multiple buttons along with fractures
to his neck.
These injuries that were going to cause him to suffering for the rest of his
life to control his pain.
Hughes sTarted taking a lot of drugs and you relied on a three part cocktail of
them,
coding,
valium and emperor emirates.
These are drugs that he took daily for the next 30 years.
Still the pain and head injuries.
They affected his behavior,
causing his ocd to spin out of control
long before his addiction to painkillers.
How would he use?
Well,
he has another addiction.
I am.
That was to winning.
When he came to hollywood in 1925,
he had a wife and an enormous sexual appetite.
The wife balance.
You'd tine of his infidelities filing for divorce in 1929.
The sexual appetite very well.
It remains end.
Was satisfied with a list of hollywood conquests that would include such stars
as peter's rita hayworth,
ava gardner,
lana turner,
and katharine hepburn.
He is well.
He was obsessed with the female form and this was actually the inspiration for
his most controversial film.
The outlaw said during the old west,
the movie was a showcase for the voluptuous Jane Russell with he used personally
ensuring that addresses where were low enough to accentuate her size.
30 eight bus.
Once again,
these centers were outraged but hughes realm,
he was laughing all the way to the bank by the mid 19 forties.
Here's his health issues were impacting upon his increasingly complicated
business empire.
In addition to his ownership of two,
the hughes tool company.
He now also owns the rko movie studio.
At the same time,
he was building a huge aerospace company to develop technology for the military
in 1947.
The pressure on here's what is ramped up several notches when he was subpoenaed
to appear before congress regarding alleged improprieties in his government
contracts in a commanding performance with the dv cameras rolling.
He strongly denied profiteering from the war effort.
What
the
that
it is sort of like running for this congressional appearance is most confident,
strong and dominant.
Public outing was also the last time that the public would see howard hughes.
The brilliance fearless,
visible millionaire.
Well,
he was transforming into a mysterious invisible.
A 53 year old use was now completely intense on retreating from society for
symptoms.
If it's undiagnosed obsessive compulsive disorder,
where buying now or to a parent,
it refused to shake hands or touch door handles.
Instructions to his aides were repeated in meticulous detail and he flew into
violent regions when things were not exactly as he had commanded,
those who worked for hughes began calling him the old man and they became
seriously concerns that he was going and seeing the fbi who are actually keeping
tabs on him noted in 1950 7:15 was the acting like inscrutable paranoiac they
added,
but it could even be capable of murder then seemingly totally out of the blue.
He was declared to that he was going to marry one of the many stylists that he
had been seeing.
Jean pinches.
Many people believe that hughes decided to get hitched so that his aides would
no longer be able to have him committed to an asylum less than a year after
marrying peter's in Nevada motel room hughes descended into one of the most
episodes of his life.
He told his aides that he wanted to view some movie.
Is it a studio on sunset boulevard?
He didn't leave that dark and screening room for more than four months.
You used to open the bag with his right hand and hold the bag out to me at a 45
degree angle,
so I reached into the bag without,
without touching the paper.
During this time,
his diet consisted of chocolate bars and milk,
and he spent his days and nights sitting naked in a chair staring at the screen.
During this time,
he was communicated with his aide,
spike scribbling on a yellow legal pad.
Instructions until you did not looking at him speaking to him unless spoken to
you first.
Over those four months of the studio,
his personal hygiene net rapidly deteriorated even as his german obsession
intensifies.
When he finally emerged from the screening room in the spring of 1958,
he was was an unkempt,
ragged sentence,
pathetic mess.
Following this,
he pretty much immediately checked into the beverly hills.
I tell them another place,
you'll only space to stay on a temporary basis,
but he was ended up staying in that for years.
Yeah.
He reverted to his screening room habits sitting naked in the dark hour after
our business dealings were conducted by telephone and through his handwritten
instructions during this time,
his drug use also escalated as he fought continuous pain.
Now injecting himself with morphine to supplement his megadoses of coding and
valium.
In 1966,
conducting negotiations completely by telephone.
Hughes sold his controlling sham in two eight.
This made him a billionaire,
the richest man in America,
but rather than simply syphilis.
Fortune hughes disliked is pathetic.
Physical condition set his sights on conquering a brand new frontier and that
front here,
what would it be?
Las vegas.
Yeah.
His first move was to relocate to the penthouse suite of the deserts in where he
could continue his bizarre lifestyle without interruption.
He then began buying up the city,
starting with the hotel that he was living in.
His investments included the local tv station which he bought so that he could
demand they play the movies that he wanted to watch.
Now by 1970,
he's.
He was a prisoner of his own design and then as if things weren't crazy enough
already,
he suddenly left the desert in without warning.
Many in his entourage,
they thought that it had been adopted.
Three weeks later,
he turns up in The Bahamas.
From that he announced that he was turning the day to day operations of his
empire over to a group of mormon aids.
In 1972,
he was relocated to a hotel room in london.
He left the room only once to go flying.
that's this was like no flight here had ever taken before.
Planning into the cockpit seat took off all of his claim in the sand to around
in london,
in the nude.
Following what would be his final flight at the helm,
hughes's condition.
Well,
it rapidly deteriorated.
He took a Fall in as london hotel room,
which increased his reliance on painkillers and unfortunately took away his
ability to work.
Things swelled.
They only went downhill from here is if by design uses last hours were spent in
the app.
It was traveling to houston to receive medical treatments is an anticipated
body.
Finally breathed his last breath on april the fifth,
1976 so well,
and it was shocked when the autopsy pictures revealed the terrible condition of
his body.
The results of undiagnosed or cd,
multiple severe head injuries and 30 years have largely selfimposed neglect.
It was so sad.
End for a truly brilliant man.
So I hope you enjoyed that video about howard hughes.
If you did do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We put on two new biographies of people like this every week,
so click that subscribe button and also if you'd like to check out some of the
videos by us,
you can find them linked to in the description below.
And as always,
thanks for watching.